[Music]
so I came across a very interesting
story it's also very sad so I'm sorry
for that
but back in March of 2018 an eleven year
old girl accidentally dropped an apple
from a balcony of the 24th floor in her
like apartment building in China and at
that exact moment when this apple fell
that's when this lady in this grandma
she was taking a walk oh [ __ ] apartment
building and it hit her with a three
month old and this Apple landed on on
the dog on the three-month-old baby's
head and was it really like she's adding
characters to the stories I don't know
as a kid I I mean I still love throwing
[ __ ] off no so she said it was an
accident because at the time this 11
year old girl was trying to feed their
family dog while holding an apple and
that's one like something happened but
she accidentally dropped the fruit and
that's when it ended up landing on this
baby's skull that's like Isaac Newton
yeah very similar so tragically though
this this baby she suffered severe head
trauma skull fractures ruptured Wow all
and traumatic shock how long does it
take for an infant's skull to become
solid because it comes out like all
mushy right yeah yeah it's like if like
three or four pieces and it's not fused
together you no matter how light that
Apple is the higher drops from do they
have Washington apples out there
it must must have been a Fuji or any
smething you [ __ ] do different apples
have different vlog I hope it's not a
green apple true different mass yeah
green apples seem harder for some reason
they are harder they're harder to bite
into and Washington apples in China Lots
hours it depends on how rich his family
is yeah there's a baby okay well what is
it what ended up happening was
that this baby underwent surgery to stop
the bleeding in her brain but she
remained in a coma
and that's when the baby's parents were
told that if she were ever to wake up
the right part of her brain would most
likely be clinically dead so she
wouldn't be very creative is that the
creative she might be really good at
math but not really good at art she
could do rocketry true but the story
here I mean that is tragic
right but the story here is the fact
that the lot 11 year old little girl's
parents are they're the ones that are
having to pay a huge price how did they
even find out that it came from that
[ __ ] building that Apple came from
you know because what they did was they
got the Apple
they took DNA samples they saved the
Apple they went through the whole
building people in that building until
they found that you loving your old
little girl Wow
and so it turns out that this selection
bit was alone in in her in the apartment
and so her parents ended up taking
responsibility for this obviously like
it's it's an accident but their child
was responsible how do you also means
they beat the living [ __ ] out yeah so
then they ended up paying the baby's
family initially 30,000 yuan which is
about four thousand seven hundred
dollars but then the baby's medical
bills kept growing and so it ended up
coming out to 130 yuan which is about
twenty thousand five hundred dollars so
when the parents paid that but then now
a couple years after this freak accident
the 11 year old girls little family was
now ordered to pay the toddler's parents
1.85 million yuan which is two hundred
and sixty one thousand dollars which has
sparked an interesting debate on Chinese
social media about like you know they
paid a lot like oh yeah so
there's people's opinions of like well
they paid the price you know like it's a
it's a tragic accident like this is no
one's fault like it wasn't malicious you
know like the medical bills have been
paid for whatever only that little girl
knows if she was malicious right but
then other people were like well you
know yeah like the the parents should be
paying for that why the [ __ ] did they
leave the little girl alone like she
shouldn't be on the 24th story all alone
with something that she can throw over
and obviously you caused harm like this
so dude this whole family when they see
apples now they like I'm part of my
brain when I read this story is like if
I was an 11 year old and I was up on a
higher I'm throwing [ __ ] boys even if
I'm not throwing stuff down part of my
brains like your parents didn't teach
you what if I didn't be but like there's
still this what if part of about your
brain which is like what if I just drop
this - you know I could you I mean your
family's from Hong Kong there's sky
roots guy scrapers everywhere yeah but I
don't think any of my family's in Hong
Kong have balconies to walk out - but if
they did you would I drop [ __ ] all the
power I'd be looking - straight down
going what happens if I just did this I
don't know if I would do it but but but
I could imagine being 11 years old being
by yourself with an apple in hand on a
balcony what are you gonna naturally
won't be curious about you know and so
part of me is like like what bart saying
like that means if it was intentional
then that means this family must have
recently moved in there because she was
like it must have been a new thing if
she wanted to intentionally do that like
well we're so high up here what would
happen you know like maybe what's the
first time she ever had an apple in her
and she was alone in the part which is
tall enough to see over the balcony
public criticize you Casey but I watched
I went down a whole during quarantine
and I watched a video of [ __ ] bunch
of dudes chucking watermelons off of a
dam and it was sick as hell look at
didn't smash yeah oh yeah smashed into a
million [ __ ] pieces I mean just like
oh sure that's really satisfying well
they let it impact impact impact and
maybe the slow motion for from five
times I mean mark Robert threw a boat
off of a tower off into a trampoline or
get a trampoline I saw that one yeah
Mike Rover
that [ __ ] was crazy I wasn't related
vids I definitely thought that yeah oh
yeah you bet your ass yeah sure did
oh you know what's funny is that well it
sucks that because I hit a baby they go
and test the entire [ __ ] building
everyone gets tested all the [ __ ] if
that hit homeless guys like look apples
fall from the sky all the time and that
crazy true is because the homeless guy
was ensuing so this family probably sued
right that's probably why well no but I
would imagine the police like who are
the ones who found out the other ones
who were able to test all these people
want you what if the grandma feels bad
for not being able protect the baby
probably I think like the baby literally
in her arm like with the baby was in the
arms and it went like that or was it in
the strollers of the grandma I mean I
mean that a pry marks you just could be
like oh that's it the grandma's fall
24th this terminal velocity so it's PI
after like five floors is the same as 20
floors what if it was the grandma's
fault where she was holding the baby and
it would have missed but just that last
second she was like just crashed your
face did you move who feels guilty and
it could be people who's my head you
know it's either grandma's face was that
day that's a good question do we do we
know that guy mo straight yeah well she
lies I feel like ya know that spot
doesn't make sense
a black Steve guard of course yeah
is being a lesbian illegal in China now
that's a joke question that's a question
that's true related to China no cuz you
know how some countries being gay is
still super illegal yeah well yeah so
there's a picture of the the building
apartment complex I already deleted it
oh damn you deleted it you just like
took closer you [ __ ] deleted that
[ __ ] I believe the whole folder it was
in there okay
can we see the a building Apple that
looks like a lay it does
oh there's Chinese the words right here
though Oh dude do you know there's
full-on cities in China
that's like Paris yeah looks like Europe
and [ __ ] like that cuz why they just
wanted to build a city that's the
replica of a European city and in it's
like Disneyland so they just built it to
look like that and there's no one living
in there yet
Wow no all right well yeah cuz they
tried getting people to move in but no
everyone was like I was there oh really
because it looks like they're made of
apples no because they're also saying
that the people that do live there they
have constant problems because it was
built so quickly that it's not even that
it's like shitty like the walls upon you
don't wait for the glue to dry start
adding another more [ __ ] and then how do
we take such a horrible story and turn
it into a positive that's your job okay
okay I gotta put the grandma's a lesbian
I love that good job
one or other terrible things are
happening right now that we can make
into a positive
okay did it have to do with apples I
know it could be anything I got I got a
pitch though because because the two
times it's car park today where people
might say to you guys and particularly
go back to China
is there a very rich province perhaps in
China where people could say very
specifically hey go back to the northern
Shanghai province of China did you look
like a very wealthy man oh thank you
there's a lot of rich place in China I
think go back to Beverly Hills that's a
compliment actually let me say that's
the kind of sting I feel when I travel
around the world is like when you go
into a store like in Europe or whatever
and they see that you're Asian there
they're already kind of like oh he's
Asian he's Chinese two five Chinese
English yeah and he's like at the
airport if you go to like airports and
you walk by and you walk into a store
they gave you all kinds of like crazy
service and the minute they hear that I
sound like Americans oz full of money
yeah he's one of those broke ones yeah
hey chief walk further away from me I
can feel rich for just a split second
that was me in Italy because me and a K
we were getting treated nice but then
once you Indiana showed up they started
treating us like [ __ ] oh yeah sure why'd
you show up looking all ghetto they
thought you guys liked the native
Italians yeah she can pass off it's
Italian and then a case wife is Filipino
and I'm Chinese so it's like an Asian
showed up and they're like they're
married to these tourists yeah how about
the entire world is institutionally
racist as [ __ ] absolutely I have never
been to a place where those people are
not racist have you did you get here but
the McDonald's story about McDonald's
kickin by people out of their vagina of
the restaurant in China yeah yeah yeah
China right now because people are like
like the rumor is that like black people
caused coronavirus so they're not
blaming
Wuhan they're blaming Africa yet the
Chinese government
blame everybody else run every group of
people chil blame someone else yeah so
they're so so well Chinese people
already have like a certain all of them
right but there's a there's already a
thing where they're over the races
against black people like Hollywood
isn't as likely to make or to advertise
movies starring black actors in China
because they're less likely to get like
theaters filled because of the things
they know the rock is black I don't know
they know because they had a whole movie
of him saving on saving a humungous
power with one leg Aziz was like
socially I mean not socially uh one of
those racially ambiguous people you're
like I don't know could be black he's
like how tiff looks Italian in Italy
yeah true just if they knew anything
everything like Djimon Honsou can't go
to China and be like hey they pronounce
his name I think so
I think Digimon isn't did you did you
mom mom [ __ ] sorry
Bart Bart corrected me think black guy
in the beginning of guardians of the
galaxy he's like I'm star Lord he's like
oh oh that guy's using almost as if
black diamond oh yeah
[Music]